- On an island off the coast of Tanzania,
are the ruins of a city that
was a hub of global trade
for centuries, right
up until the Europeans
showed up and spoiled everything.
I'm Samir Patel, deputy
editor of Atlas Obscura,
and this is Kilwa Kisiwani.
To get to the ruins of Kilwa
Kisiwani, you first have to get
to the tiny island of
Kilwa Masoko, get a permit,
and then head to the dock at
the southern end of the island
and convince someone who has
a boat to take you across.
As soon as you wade through
the surf to the island,
you'll find yourself in the
ruins of maybe the greatest
city of the Swahili culture.
Before Europe's Age of
Exploration, starting
in the 10th century, a bunch
of rich sultanates arose
on the East African coast, kind of like
the city-states of Renaissance Italy.
The biggest was Kilwa Kisiwani,
which made its fortunes
by playing the global
markets, trading the riches
of the African interior
(gold, ivory, timber, spices, even slaves)
to the Middle East, India,
and then on to Europe
and even to China.
It was even mentioned in
John Milton's "Paradise Lost"
as one of the great kingdoms of the Earth.
The site today is a ruin,
but the standing remains are spectacular.
They're all made of giant blocks
of limestone called coral rag.
You'll see the Great Mosque,
it's the oldest standing
mosque in the region
which had 16 domes originally
(10 of them of still intact).
You'll see a fort called
Husuni Ndogo, and the remains
of a bunch of other, smaller buildings.
But the real highlight, which
you have to take a boat to
because it's on the other side
of a mangrove forest, is Husuni Kubwa,
the grand palace built by
Sultan al-Hasan ibn Sulaiman
in the 14th century, at the
height of the city's power.
You have to enter by boat,
at the base of a cliff,
and then you climb these
worn stairs to the hilltop
to the ruins of the palace.
There's a giant cliffside octagonal bath,
a residence with 100 rooms,
a stepped greeting court,
with candle niches in the wall.
But it was a little too ambitious.
For some reason we don't know,
the sultan never finished it.
The question of who built
this city was much debated
in the early 20th century.
Old accounts said it was
founded by a Persian prince
who bought the island from
a local king for cloth,
enough cloth to encircle the whole island,
and then destroyed the bridge
that connected it to the mainland.
This actually turned
out to be a classic bit
of colonial thinking, that
Africans couldn't possibly
have built such an international,
sophisticated city,
a multicultural center,
and a global trade network.
Later excavations at
another of the stone towns
on the Swahili coast, Shanga in Kenya,
show clearly that the Swahili culture
was homegrown in Africa
and it picked Islam
and its architectural styles-
the minarets, the mosques, the domes-
to make itself more
appealing to Arab traders.
They cherry-picked their
influences from the successful
parts of other cultures until it all came
to an end in the 16th century.
That's when the Portuguese
showed up, building forts,
demanding tribute, and
generally mucking things up.
A lot of the stone towns
were hastily abandoned
around this time, and though
it's hard to say exactly why,
losing control of the
trade that made them rich
was probably a big part of it.
So this is one of the great, little-known
and little-studied medieval civilizations
of the world, like a Venice of its time.
And it's actually not really gone.
There's still nearly 2
million people living on the
East African coast who identify as Swahili
and millions more who speak the language.
Thank you for watching,
if you like this video, please subscribe.
Click here for more videos and tell us
what you think in the comments.
Where do you think we should explore next?